trap darling that's the battle ax except
gosh did this really autocross you fish
take baths of dogs bigger may take back
apologies drove you to rebreathe
atrocities ducking Boris stick quickly
away dftb dftb eta is your food stopping
for you I'm listing Facebook to bloody
and dig dig I came down for the biggest
surprise for the death mother son became
a drug fish drug beating hair Debbie
talks dangerous five
don't use to be afraid
what you mean
is explained
TV dftb dftba dftb dftb dftba dftb dftb
dftba it's so damn fine to be alive
until your goofy part interface brother
arrives
Stansfield burning is Tony the one
association or the bows aberration - I
was very p.m. TBD TBD PA get frogs teach
board anatomist silikal faves that
blindly assist duel for the best acronym
and dark first of only apprehend
desperately pharmacy agent was destined
for the burger anyway district on
please
please explain
dftba
to be a damn TBD
BBA do you have to be do
oh and hey oh and hey oh and hey like it
says on my friend Katie's online don't
forget to be awesome
oh and Hank like it says on my turn
piggies arms don't forget to be awesome
oh and hey like it says in their
importance a lens like it says on my
friend Cody's a lot alike
what is the
forgive me
I am you
we need you
it's time
as he might expect that was not 100% my
work thank you to all of the
nerdfighters who suggested dftba
acronyms and all the nerdfighters who
Illustrated dftba acronyms but most of
all most importantly the most abhorred
person of this entire project with
Michael Aranda so I wrote a bunch of rap
lyrics and I was like I don't know how
to turn this into a song so I instant
message Michael Aranda and he was like
that guy's so cool you need to go
subscribe to him right now go subscribe
to him and I will see all of you very
soon dftb dftb dftba i spat on my camera